how are you John I'm doing good I'm just
hopeful hopeful we get the game in the
night yeah before we get to that though
John cuz I always appreciate when you
call and I know that your schedule is
very tight since you're going to the
game tonight I know that the call you
really wanted to hear wasn't Gregg Birds
home run but it was really this one this
is for you John
well corn takes the snap Ralston was
right going for the endzone
Hail Mary if they're good the Spartans
break it up as time runs out
the Spartans win at Michigan 14 to 10
what do you think John do you know how
much laundry I had to do after that game
I mean you realize that not only was one
of the worst football games I've ever
watched but I'm always on the other side
of that like it's not like the history
of Favre or Brady and you know the last
drive is gonna go your way mm-hmm I I
watched a mistake after mistake and I
just still can't believe the game was
won that's probably the third game where
Mother Nature has given us a chance to
win and I'm just impressed that you were
able to to actually play that again this
day I am not kidding you this this has
to be more painful yes then then the
foot the block punt because that there
wasn't much expected you know going into
that no John if we really want to get
deep into my soul and psyche that that
punt that blot that that that botched
faith snap that one particularly hurt
cuz Michigan State was really really
good and that was a measuring stick in
Harbaugh's first year and to come out
and their first big game and for Paul
Bunyan that one hurt that one hurt a lot
yeah you know well I I again I can
appreciate you being stand up I have not
heard from one out there not one I mean
it is like these yeah we ghost they all
got new phones
witness protection it was uh that's so
congratulations on that on the big win
for your yourse party right there John
well thank you and like I said this year
there wasn't much expected from us so
we'll see if they could sneak out a few
more wins alright let's get into the
weather report so it is it it is a
concern for the weather for tonight's
game for the Yankees yeah it's good it's
an Indian's every day obviously or every
moment of the day it seems to get a
little better when you look at the
forecast long-range so at least two good
things one I didn't know that Boston
would be playing now so the fact that
they're they're playing and the
weather's been okay there but we're not
in Boston tonight it's supposed to get a
little bit better as the night goes on
because there's a lot of factors that
come into this game not being played of
course you'd have to play tomorrow that
changes a lot of strategy for two
different managers so hopefully we get
then and I anticipated this series from
the beginning too many people follow the
storylines and jump off the ship too
quickly this was going to be a really
good series regardless or who want and
it's shaping up to be that way well I
mean obviously one assumes the Yankees
would have won had you're already
challenged and that the challenge had
gone the way that we all assumed that it
would have is any fan of football
definitely knows when you challenge
something anything it's like a slot
machine you pull the arm you have no
idea what's gonna come out even though
you think you see what you see all that
said how did you take the non challenge
from Girardi on Friday night John well
yeah I mean uh you know in the booth
watching the game live sometimes look
people forget that you know the game
moves fast for a lot of people it's not
just players the managers and the
coaches have to make split decisions
have to make decisions that they're
either going to not be happy with or be
happy with and I'm not talking about
decisions on who to put in when those
are obvious
Goll was going to be you know
second-guessed and that's part of being
a manager today with all the information
but I think as he looks back and as he
talked to us he said you know it hurts
he messed up and it hurts because he's
so passionate about everybody he's not
just passionate about his players front
office
fans and I think it's just so easy to
pile on yes that was a situation where
when you slow everything down and look
back and go oh yeah I should have
challenged regardless of the information
I got or didn't get having said that you
know the execution also of a team that
has to use its bullpen so much I've been
saying this forever and the analytical
world just turns a deaf D deaf ear to it
because they don't want they don't want
these results they just want to be able
to prove they're right all the time you
can't keep doing this kind of baseball
and expect you're going to have fresh
arms all the time out of the pen and
they paid a price for winning that game
with their starter home and going to
third and they will continue to pay a
price if their starters don't give you
more outings like Tanaka and their
bullpens fantastic it's the best
collection of arms I've seen in a long
time but you still have to trust and get
some work out of your starters because
that's what makes Cleveland so good yeah
I know and then CC came out with 77
pitches and Tanaka I mean I mean you're
already could have gone to him in the
eighth and it said he found it he went
from being up 1-nothing with a starter
that was lights out to 1 hat third of an
inning later going to his closer for a 5
out save I mean talk about dealing from
a position of strength making it into
weakness again they got out they got the
1 nothing win but what so what's if the
rain doesn't arrive what in the world is
Chapman going to look like tonight John
yeah he'll be available for an inning I
would imagine I mean you know they they
were from a strength the weakness no
doubt and the problem with managers have
today is they're such an overkill of
information like I just mentioned where
everybody says you have to win that game
and there's a little bit of a lack of
trust to trust that the guy that's on
the mound currently is legitimately
locked in and you can't lump him in with
the previous innings of Statistics what
you hear constantly from everyone in the
in the industry is the third time around
the lineup these are the averages yeah
maybe on norm but on a given day you
have to trust your eyes at times I did
last night think that was the right
decision however because of the exertion
that
naca gave you for the last two innings
he was on balloon I've never seen his
split with that velocity so he was
literally tapping out and and dominating
so I didn't have a problem with that
there's games in the past that have
drove me crazy where you take out a
starter and the other team and the other
dugout is going thank you because
there's no guarantees that five more
guys that come in the game are going to
have their a stuff the more pictures you
Pittsburgh aim the less likelihood
they're all going to be on their game
it's like rolling the dice a little bit
even though there's some great arms so
you know Cleveland you saw this last
year Cleveland was they did an
unbelievable job with their pen that got
to the World Series they had one and a
half starters they ran out of gas it was
it became obvious by the seventh game
but they got to the seventh game the
amount of work it's going to take for
the Indians to win this series will have
its toll there will be a toll on Chapman
tonight there's no doubt Joe knows that
but they had to get to tonight maybe
tonight there'll be a five run lead
that's what you hope when you're you're
kind of getting through the individual
game that the next game will take care
of itself
couple more minutes with the baseball
hall-of-famer John Smoltz of MLB Network
and Fox Sports here on the Rich Eisen
show Dodgers up - oh they can go for the
knockout blow and then you've got
obviously what's going on in Fenway Park
right now in the game that you're
calling tonight between the Yankees and
the Indians and this is the best part
about postseason play John is we could
talk about the Cubs this the Cubs that
they didn't look the same that they they
look pedestrian but when it all comes
down to it somebody is gonna have to
knock off the defending champs and this
thing between the Nationals and the Cubs
is a slobberknocker I love it how do you
see the rest of this series playing out
yeah I selfishly wish it was best of
seven but you know I selfishly wish
every series is best to seven because
that truly is what baseball threw 162
games has become the best-of-five a
little bit more of a flip of the coin
less room for error I love this series I
thought that each series honestly in the
playoffs this year had the makings of
some great drama and some great baseball
but early on is surprisingly a lot of
great starters got knocked out so early
on you got kind of like this bell rung
for a lot of teams and they went right
to their pen
unlike the Cubs and Nationals that
hasn't been the case right at a gem game
one was a really well pitched game Game
two and now you've got what you thought
was going to be Game one starters I
believe it's Scherzer and Arrieta that
corrects Quintana at best we can tell
right now unless Arrieta still backed up
I just think that these two teams I've
I've loved the Nationals all year I love
their starting pitching I mean they they
didn't get some hitting until the 8th
inning so that might wake them up
storylines can you can i I've been in a
hundred game five series and you just
have to tell the guys in the clubhouse
don't pay attention don't fall off the
teeter-totter
you know like this ain't over and there
were not done because those those
storylines switched so quickly after
Game one in Cleveland this series was
over Kluber is going game too well you
saw what happened then Game three this
is over you know Cleveland's gonna win
you just can't follow it and you've got
to make your breaks and you've got to be
as prepared as possible to advance
because then once you get to a
best-of-seven and you lose there is
nothing you can say that team was better
than you John always love chatting with
you especially listening you call a game
you're awesome and you and bascarsija
we're a great listen and it's it's just
been fun it's been fun
I appreciate that thanks for having me
and don't forget John who's the Michigan
man who presented himself after that
loss who's that guy who stood tall you
have no idea what that means and how far
slotted everyone else has gone I mean
there's take care of John all right you
guys John smokes the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to